these migrants have nowhere to go
they're stranded in a refugee camp in
bosnia herzegovina
their goal is to reach western europe
but for now their focus
is surviving the winter storm the lipa
camp near the croatian border has no
heat and no proper facilities
lined outside in sub-zero temperatures
refugees wait for a donated meal
and perhaps a sleeping bag from the red
cross
we are living like animals even animal
living like better us so
please i request uh uno iom
all ngos to help us
because if they cannot help us we will
die
so please help us a fire broke out on
wednesday
the same day the camp was meant to be
shut down
a u.n official says it was likely set by
migrants
frustrated with the scheduled closure
and lack of alternatives
now most of the infrastructure that
house more than 1500 people
is destroyed or damaged there is
no anything and no blankets no
better place for sleeping you know there
is a many problems
and i think we will be dying there are
reports of frostbite and hypothermia
proper shoes is a luxury many here can't
afford
the eu has warned bots near the
thousands of migrants face a freezing
winter without shelter
but politics is getting in the way
plans to relocate migrants have been met
with protests and resistance from
residents
and authorities have so far failed to
find new accommodations for thousands of
people from asia
the middle east and north africa the
situation has been described as a
disaster
upon a disaster and the u.n is concerned
things could get worse katya lopez
obayan
al jazeera